after the experience in brazil with jess
i think colt knows that i'm not in favor
of this relationship
it's um rebound for one and desperation
for another
but i have to respect cold and this is
something that he has to decide for
himself
we all can make mistakes doesn't mean we
shouldn't be forgiven
she was upset so do you think she loves
you
i do yelling at you screaming at you
that's love
it's passion she's a latina she has that
fire
i love her
that's not excused
you know i think she should come out
here
stay with us to try again with you
are you okay with that i think we can
try again in vegas
i love jess i think she's a great girl
and i want to move forward
in our relationship
all right
okay
are you gonna tell jess beforehand
about vanessa
i don't know
i feel horrible because i actually have
been keeping another thing from jess
you're gonna wait to surprise her
a few days after i returned from brazil
vanessa was having a hard time during
her divorce and
needed a place to stay
my mother invited her to stay with us so
vanessa is not my roommate
you